à paris la séance est européenne quel
commentaire
journées supplémentaires de détention
pour marseille cartonne martin fontaine
jean paul kauffmann jean louis normandin
antennes de hergé rô les otages français
au liban non plusieurs pages étaient
libérés balayé la bourse de paris recule
air qui s'ajoutent aux pertes déjà
conséquences de la première à l'heure
des comptes
les spécialistes sont formels le mois
boursier d'autres corps affichera un
déficit encore les cochers voir quelle
était l'ambiance
la bourse de paris la foule des grands
jours était venu à la chute
la valeur a perdu
notre de l'économie et des finances
reste serein j'ai des choses à long
terme et non pas en fonction
piètre consolation la bourrasque a
touché l'ensemble des places partout les
lois les marchés financiers dans la
déprime et en grande bretagne
le point avec nous aujourd'hui 10 de 50
milliards de francs de la pêche
la première 3 mai ajoutant grandes
devises et vend de l'école est en baisse
le mois dernier de 0 8% des scandales
comme attendu mais la confiance dans la
cité enfin la tempête des questions aux
prétendus chacun se demande d'autant que
ce tout se passe actuellement à
francfort la belge de l' indice atteint
5,6 pour cent avec dans la chimie une
perte de 13 7% pour la bundesbank a dû
acheter pour près de 10 millions de
dollars
ça me soutenir la monnaie américaine la
chute du billet vert comprenez les
perspectives d'exportations des sociétés
allemandes
le ministre de l'économie avec ici à un
art 80 le seul sensible du dollar pour
l'économie du pays avait été pourtant
semaine dernière une crise qui tourne
mal
j'ai encouragé par une marianne la
bourse américaine déclarations du
secrétaire d'état au trésor kenneth
baker la possibilité de représailles
américaines aujourd'hui par lui même
doté pas à new york
le commentaire de bonheur
une heure avant la ferme tout wall
street la baisse du dow jones étaient
280 points un record a très bien le
dollar aussi détendu la commission
américaine des opérations en bourse
envisage désormais d'intérêt de marché
pour tenter d'enrayer la spirale de la
tête 85 qui s'est passé
58 ans 24 octobre prochain les baissé
d'à peine 13 cents de plus de 30%
milliards de son côté depuis la fin du
dernier c'est un nouveau record
on a perdu l'équivalent de 5 milliards
c'est vous dire de 87,7
le bc la nécessité de redonner un
certain point le marché boursier pour
que l'europe comme total
parce que tout fonctionnait certains
disent que les conditions d'un
apaisement passe par une certaine
impatience
american respectivement une réunion
entre elles de diffusion et erik jan
bucquoy les millions de petits porteurs
pour vous je suis déjà que jeudi
prochain
arrêtez 1h55 une autre émission sera
entièrement consacrée à l'étranger après
la marine américaine avec des
plateformes pétrolières
c'est la réponse des américains à la
tactique à la défense a confirmé
officiellement
le raid de représailles en précisant que
les plateformes abriter des radars
surveillant la navigation dans le golfe
quant à ronald reagan le président vous
parle ce soir de répondre prudent et
limité à washington commentaire de
châtel bouchard
les installations en flammes se seraient
détruites par quatre ont déployé de lui
et ce n'est dit à 250 km à l'est de
bahreïn dans le golfe persique
caspar weinberger cette affaire la
défense indiqué que le personnel iranien
avait investi fall générique 1 20
minutes avant la claque
le ministre a précisé que la plateforme
équipée de canons anti-aériens n'avait
pas riposté à l'action américaine des
représailles francs suite à la
destruction partielle vendredi dernier
les pétroliers atteint par un missile
dernier ainsi le poids le porte-parole
de la maison blanche
l'animateur s'appelle c'est l'ajout des
destroyers de répondants stylisée à
l'attaqué contre le pétrolier le
président légal a décrété samedi soir la
décision d'une opération de représailles
après une réunion avec ses conseillers
les états unis un droit pour justifier
leur action tout à l'heure la maison
blanche nous ne cherchons pas la
confrontation avec terrain mais se fera
à une oreille d'opposants
autrement dit il y aura d'autres
représailles plus important si
nécessaire au cas où téhéran se
lancerait dans une escalade militaire
4 nous donner une impulsion
supplémentaire relations c'est la
quatrième music bêta entreprises par un
président français depuis le voyage
historique en 1962 aujourd'hui devant
les étudiants et les universitaires a
lancé un appel aux partenaires
présidé ce matin la séance solennelle de
rentrée après une occasion monsieur
mitterrand de lancer un vibrant appel à
une europe de la culture le cas des
raisons de venir nous prononçons mal
dans man pour dire à tous ceux que l'on
devienne européenne puisqu'il tire tout
en restant fidèle à tous en voilà une
s'agit seulement de rencontrer des
hommes politiques mais de s'adresser à
l'ensemble un peu blasé peut-être ici le
plateau était avant cela brio mais avec
l'allemagne
c'est certain la précarité
ce soir lundi 31 mai à partir de 20h30
telle information
aujourd'hui la bourse où les questions
de la crise financière risque d'un choc
violent fronde contre m les tenues
française qui va se retourner
mentalement contre et ailleurs dans ce
prix est conforme à cette crise n'est
pas due uniquement à l'amérique elle est
d'abord née des richesses dans les
entreprises du profit pour la situation
financière et les jo en deuxième lieu la
main à l'image de la france à l'inscrire
états unis et c'est pourquoi nous
proposons je propose des mesures qui
visent à faire revenir l'argent pour la
production et qui vise à donner une
indépendance à la france
votre avis ce guide
cela dit sera le seul à demander l'arrêt
des privatisations est certes mais pas
dans les bars public serbe a été la
production ça s'est fait à bas taux
d'intérêt dont la production au lieu de
dilapider l'argent
vous parlez de la candidature rouquin
c'est une attitude de façade impression
de là mais sur le terrain la concorde
nationale a voté sur scène puisqu'il y
avait dit tu pouvais être candidat il ya
eu zéro voix
j'étais à l'unanimité et ce à quoi j'ai
fait un petit tour de sens personne ne
m'a parlé de cette candidature qui
d'ailleurs aurait dû avoir l'on accepté
de démissionner du parti opposé au
candidat de l'unité aucun parti de
comair connaissez ma prétendue membres
s'opposent aux candidats qu'ils aient 18
merci on voit pour ce soir à vous poser
des questions
maintenant le 47,87 prix 12 appelé de la
trace des deux malfaiteurs après midi
les clients tué par un gendarme et un
douanier de la crise le plan vautours
mise en place par la gendarmerie n'a
rien donné
pour l'instant on n'a toujours pas le
câliner la mercedes gris métallisé de la
rentrera à laquelle se trouvaient les
deux agresseurs repartent à de relance
italie la recherche du côté suisse que
du côté français les enquêteurs sur
leurs gardes qui chaque jour à faire de
véritables professionnels
hier à 15h20 il relève se présente à ce
péage proche de là
une mercedes présente à son tour les
données de valeur s'est passé en
quelques secondes
quelques kilomètres du péage il force la
barrière de certains services depuis les
enquêteurs ont perdu leur trace un crime
que les gendarmes explique parce que
contenait le poids de la mère a
découvert une chose étrangère est
également ce qui a provoqué la réaction
du conducteur de la mercedes
un chargeur contenant ce soir toujours à
la recherche de lundi ce qui pourrait
leur permettre de commencer l'anc est
pour le moment un seul élément sérieux
les policiers de signalement des deux
frères pourraient correspondre aux coûts
importants les enquêteurs n'étaient
encore la série d'attentats il semble
suivre qu'elle qualifie d' agents du
colonialisme
le point avec catherine une mise en
scène spectaculaire
axel kahn ou les treillis réglementaire
rien ne manquait à l'appel pour cette
conférence de presse car dès la première
depuis six mois au programme la nouvelle
stratégie indépendante ainsi le slogan
qui tranche et du fort français dehors
il semble plus être à l'ordre du jour
nous ne menons pas une lutte anti
françaises a déclaré le porte parole de
l'ex écurie
quant aux corses certains risquent
d'être pris pour cible parce qu'ils
représentent les relais du colonialisme
et d'annoncer la nécessité d'intensifier
les actions nul ciblées contre les
continentaux incitations après la prise
d'eau par un passage à la d'avoir de
grands dinosaures
entièrement détruit un premier
appartenait à jean mis la manière
employée par le rectorat ancien assureur
parisien déjà quitté l'île par deux fois
il a eu tort de l'apn s'est ouvert 84
les critiques des militants
indépendantistes au parmi lesquels jean
marie vidal aujourd'hui 107 dans le box
des accusés tous inculpé d'assassinats
et de violences volontaires avec la
surveillante qui a qu'une chance de
réconcilier d'algol chez canal c'est
vous les accusés sont des natifs ce qui
ne fait que compliquer la faire écouter
184 la flicaille nguene devenu pour les
kanaks le symbole de la lutte en faveur
des parents d'une personne tuée au cours
d'une embuscade tout près du village de
jean marie tjibaou
trois ans après les actes commis par les
yankees indépendante il a toujours la
légitime défense
à l'époque la justice avait conclu nous
depuis le jugement était annulé
le nouveau procès qui demain séminaire
sera à l'origine il n'y a par exemple
jamais eu de reconstitution de la
retenir
quelle que soit la décision du tribunal
condamnation pas une partie de la
population calédonienne claira de toute
façon scandale à procès à l'image la
situation économique du territoire
une situation qui se résume en un mot le
blocage
le record dans ma mère ne comparez pas
mécanique avancée minutes
une information démentie
l'action grâce à l'autonomie après on a
déconné c'est peut-être poussé par alain
prost dans ses derniers retranchements
si la matière dans la tête par les
commissaires pour des raisons de
sécurité aucune plainte n'a été déposée
le résultat big man est entériné
n'empêche le rendu final
toujours équipé mais pas comme un
partisan depuis une trentaine d'heures
les conditions étaient relativement
clément partir au fur à mesure et
notamment le classement est toujours le
même c'est donc pour elle cela est
ridicule qui toujours en tête
il possède maintenant nous allons le
voir sur l'image il possède maintenant
une avance sur le second qui est bruno
peran les différences la même bateau
comment lakers en mission demeure pas
paru l'an dernier
il faudrait bien courte et la plus
grande qualité de sentiments et sa
récurrence dans l'otan le passage de
demain matin
mais aussi par la carte et du temps
qu'il fera
à la mi journée nous le demandions à
tous enfin donc légèrement vers les lois
trop forte
voilà donc deux mois
enfin la bourse rappelle pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent que l'intro du jour
c'est évidemment la chute des marchés
financiers je suis favorable à wall
street
merci d'un cinéma jorian sur tous les
fronts hommes d'affaires la production
une société qui marche bien donc
clairement une coproduction avec de
multiples et gérard mordillât sortira
mercredi prochain
on y voit jean yanne aux côtés de
thierry lhermitte c'est l'histoire d'une
amitié étrange entre deux voyous se
retrouver comme en 1940
qu'est-ce qui a assisté au tournage
durant quelques années avec toujours le
même sens dramatique s'arrêter fait
toujours sentir de manière
sorti sur les écrans d'information 23h40
avec hervé claude avant cela n'oubliez
pas l'heure des vérités à 20h30
l'émission 30 ans de vacances à la
télévision afin que bizarre parce
excellente soirée sur la précision des
mains dans télématin gérard morin
accueillera verrez vous voir l'ancien
ministre de l'économie